Ramzi personality chris hogan number one
best-selling author of the book retire
inspired joins me this hour as we talked
to millionaires everyday millionaires
theme hour and man we enjoy talking to
these folks
ashish is with us to start us off in
Chicago hey ash what is your net worth
it's a pleasure talking to you you too
what's your net worth what my net worth
is 1.2 million very cool good and tell
me how that's broken down what's that
invested in it's 600 and retirement fund
you want 15 stocks and mutual funds I
have an equity of about 250 on my house
equity of fifty thousand on our rental
property I have six thousand and my
emergency funds and thirty thousand an
hour 529 plan you are killing it well
done
so how old are you thank you my wife and
I both know man you're way ahead of
schedule
so how much of this 1.2 million is there
because you inherited it okay very good
so you completely do this yourself by 38
years old so what has been your income
range your household income like your
lowest point and your highest point came
in this country in 2008 and at that
point of time all combined whole and
$60,000 we would have a combined house
one of lutely about 300,000 very cool
what do you guys do for a living I am
insurance company and my wife works as
manager for one of the airline companies
in Chicago very cool so what's your
degree in people monsters and computer
applications okay very cool and your GPA
education out sort of us so we don't
really have to construct you here but
they don't worry about tree okay got it
and how much of this money is here
because you borrowed money to create
wealth
the only thing we have bottles for is
our house did you have the mortgage on
and the rental property and to be honest
a couple of years and I started
listening to your show you had done some
mistakes to be honest we we had garnets
on both of our cars that was the first
thing which we paid off because we had
cash ready with us but for some reason
we were still keeping our car loans go
on we could borrow the money on the car
loans a couple of years back but since
the time you started listening to your
shows you don't have anything bottles
besides our house right you said you
emigrate it to the country what from
where did you grow up in India India
okay and you came here for work gotcha
John sure okay because I read a
statistic awhile back that that I
believe to be true it's an old statistic
and so I don't know if it's accurate
today I don't have I mean it's it's
probably a 40 year old statistic but it
said that people who come to this
country legally from another country are
four times more likely to end up being
millionaires than one of us who grew up
here because you came here because of
the opportunity and by god you're gonna
take advantage of it would that be true
in your case I come few days and let me
ask you this would your would your
cultural upbringing have been an
advantage when you came to America or a
disadvantage as far as building wealth I
mean did you where there's some good
things that you learn you know growing
up in your culture that work to your
advantage when you came here or some
things that held you back well it did
not inherit any function my parents on
the fortune for my parents for my
household
but the thing which really helped out as
couples was the fact that our enduring
always give us a value for money so I
don't know even done the age of 26 right
so when I started my first job back in
idea the poison my father did at that
point of time was to sit with me and
divide by n come to all different
buckets of defense along with the
savings so from day one for my first
paycheck there was a push for me to save
money and that's what really helped as a
culture and like that always a change
and now he say
and I see 78 years old he has never
borrowed a single penny even the house
we build was completely on his cash
support and the concept of me borrowing
the money for the for the house itself
was something that she was not very
comfortable back right so even that kind
of debt he went bananas on he didn't
like it so let me ask you this is that a
particular to your family or do you feel
like that was a cultural norm that would
be different the cultural shift in some
of the Asian countries which had the
strong value its kind of a little bit
but should I compare to the American and
some of the Western cultures the feeling
of savings and the power of the money
and the power of savings it's been a
little stronger and the value in vibe is
a little stronger compared to some of
the Asian countries what we have it's a
good discussion it's good thing to
explore Chris it really is that sees do
you do any giving I do not like to it
yes but we do try to do as much as we
can both over here okay very good and I
have to ask you what's the most you've
ever paid for a pair of jeans 30 okay
all right
and did you ever buy a new car prior to
becoming a millionaire on many vine two
years back and that was the one that we
are having okay I cheese tell me you do
have kids right okay I was gonna say
because if you bought a minivan and
didn't have kids we were gonna have to
talk so I'm glad you congratulations
very cool very well done it's a good
discussion and here's the thing Chris I
have I started noticing this many years
ago I had a lady call me that was German
and came here right after World War 2
her husband was actually in German army
in World War 2 so if you came to the
United States right after World War two
with a German accent you were not a
popular person right I mean as you can
imagine and so
her husband was killed in the war and
she came to the United States to set a
new future for her kids and when you set
when you have a long term goal that's
beyond your own life when you live like
no one else to be able to live like no
one else there's something about you
know if you're willing to pick your
family up completely uproot out of the
culture of your upbringing change
languages often be a religious minority
often do although all of that sacrifice
in order to get opportunity you take
advantage of that opportunity oh
absolutely
treasure it yes the Statue of Liberty
means something in the world well
they're not gonna squander it I mean
there's too much on the line Dave and I
can you know as a redneck hillbilly I
can take a lesson from that I can't you
go hey this is the land of the free yes
this is the home of the brave yes I can
do this yes and you know I'm working on
this next book project and it's one of
those things that I keep going to my
stain to myself the American Dream is
still available don't anybody dare tell
you that it's not possible you can't do
it or you shouldn't do it that's a lie
and it's one of those things I get I get
I get excited hearing these people that
have sacrificed like you said he's not
been here just a little over 10 years
and has hit 1.2 million dollars in so
you said why not me that's right
you know right absolutely where you
don't have the language barrier you
didn't have to learn the language you
you were growing here in America where
opportunity is on every corner and
that's almost a problem it's almost a
thing you can squander something that
you take for granted you feel entitled
well all of us I mean I can look at
myself and say that and then you know
not as much because I'm a go-getter
capitalist Pig I believe in this stuff
right but um you know you know the
reason we do this our for you folks
listening Chris and I is we have come to
believe that it is harder for some
people than others but it's possible for
almost everyone that's a perfect way to
put that I mean there there's all the
isms racism sexism hillbilly ism you
know you can get you can get put down a
push back or a press for anything I mean
there's people won't put me on the radio
because they think I'm broadcasting from
a double-wide so that's hillbilly ism
right
held back so but I mean you can be put
down pushed back oppressed by anybody
from any people group and and and some
people more of that than others that
they have to overcome but we are finding
people that are overcoming all the isms
yes they are on a daily basis Dave and
it just exciting it is exciting cuz it
means you can do it too it's available
you can do it yes it's doable every day
millionaires theme hour back with more
of these real stories from real people
not theories from the news channel not
someone who's writing a blog in their
mother's basement this is real life boys
and girls this is the Dave Ramsey chef